for sarah carter on the ground in
arlington virginia tonight where she
asked democrats what they thought about
biden's terrible first nine months in
office sarah this is going to get
interesting
yeah it is going to get very interesting
sean i got to tell you it's a chilly
night here people did show up but the
interesting thing was is that because
glenn younkin and terry mcauliffe are
both tied in for this race i mean they
are neck and neck with only seven days
left a lot of terry mccullough's
supporters are kind of avoiding reality
it's not just about biting but it's
about terry mcauliffe himself his
support for a critical race theory in
the schools his also statements that he
made that parents should be hands off on
their children's education i want you to
listen to this
is there any concern with terry
mccullough and glenn young getting so
close neck and neck especially in a
state like virginia
do you think too though that maybe
mcauliffe's actions in the school when
he said you know parents got to stay out
of the public school uh system hands off
that that could have affected it a
little bit and
terry didn't say that the way i look at
public education while parent
involvement is important
if they want
more control over their child's
curriculum
there are other options other than
public education do you think though
that it has anything to do at all with
like the fact that there's a lot of
parents in loudoun county and any of
that
with the schools with what mcauliffe was
saying about parents hands off on
sean you can see there were some people
that were just a little bit rude when i
pressed on those questions and i you
know that's understandable they are
really backing terry mcauliffe here
because this is a blue area and this is
kind of the reason why biden showed up
here arlington is is definitely more
blue than it is red uh but when you talk
to people who support glenn younkin
they'll all say you know you'll never
see a rally like this in loudoun county
right now sean
how about how many people showed up
tonight sarah
well they were roughly estimating around
2 000 people now that's give or take
it was extremely small compared to the
rallies that we've seen with president
trump and others and also because this
area is so blue we were expecting a lot
more people now that could have been due
to the chilly weather we don't know but
but biden did not draw in the crowds
that were expected today and and neither
did terry mcauliffe yeah donald trump
used to get crowds remind me i think 40
000 people and another 30 thousand
outside uh big difference
yeah
all right
by the way and it didn't seem like you
got recognized uh that's good probably
uh especially if you're associated with
this show in in hostile territory uh
sarah carter thank you okay i was
completely honest completely honest
we appreciate that report thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else